[Musique]
bonjour la réunion bon choix le monde
comment ils les marmailles c'est soit
les biens moins mal aimé mieux me valait
mieux aujourd'hui ousseynou laye nous
les aux avirons chez monsieur et madame
roche
qu'est ce qu'on fait ici on vient voir
leur élevage de pigeons
oui madonna un élevage pigeon un tapis
sont pas tous comme ça dans les pas
sorti de l'auberge
c'est insolite c'est génial on a donc et
vous venez
riche vers mon binôme horodateurs
[Musique]
pas
bonjour monsieur bonjour bonjour madame
roche cachette pas alors monsieur roche
déjà merci d'accueil à nous ici déjà et
au diamant où ça nous a là on est sauvés
ou fait on est aux avirons plus
précisément au chemin bellecombe et on
est dans un élevage de pigeons de chair
fusion de chercheurs de attention c'est
pas ce type fusion en moins ils trouvent
un homme non non non non non non moi je
propose quelque chose m'a déjà on va
voir les pigeons et on va en parler
il n'y a pas de sujet on y parlera en
c'est parti mais avant il faudra mettre
des charmantes petites chaussures
magnifique j'adore
il tombe bien mardi la chambre
d'histoire et on compte voilà malin tu
me sembles donc
ça y est
j'en avais
m
non
[Musique]
des gens dont on commence à en voir
comment à sa rentrée on commence à
entendre autrement sens et c'est un
bruit que nous nous on n'entend plus dé
monsieur roche mais la nana quelques eps
pigeon un an à quelques dizaines à huy
et donc je dirais même quelques
centaines en tout combien de figeons
nana dans doit avoir
dans l'est au moins 1500 entre 1500 et
2000 puis 1500 2000 puis j'en ai dit moi
est-ce que nana plusieurs variétés où on
a plusieurs variétés
on a dû du hub l blanc qui sait ça on a
eu du bain une belle rouge
on peut voir là dedans d'accord on a une
autre variété une nouvelle variété c'est
de myrtille ce blanc vous disais tout à
l'heure bien précisé au début de
l'émission des pigeons de chair voilà
parce qu'ils lisent beaucoup de variétés
de pigeons il ya des pigeons de chair il
ya des pigeons de collection ca c c'est
un pigeon qui est fait à la base
uniquement pour sa viande
voilà donc je mangerai pas manger
absolument le pigeon le à la base c'est
le hib elle est appelée double poitrine
un pigeon de kathryn lasky est tellement
bombay dessous donc
c'est d'après pigeons à double
[Musique]
m
et donc là dedans les parent père est ce
que les couples de pigeons est ce que
les fidèles et ça et ben voila voila il
faudrait prendre l'exemple dessus ils se
débrouillent tout seuls débrouille on
doit manger on donne à boire on donne
tout ce qu'il faut et il se débrouille
ils nourrissent le petit jusqu'au
jusqu'au dernier jour ah ouais aurait
cédé petit à l'intérieur d'un des petits
chats d'intérieur
non non non non ce jeu rien on récupère
les petites toutes les semaines qui vont
aller directement à l'abattoir
il faut savoir que le pigeon c'est
l'animal qui prend du poids qui prend du
poids plus vite que tous les autres que
tous les autres animaux
un pigeon il double son poids pendant
les sept premiers jours il va doubler
son poids de jour en jour donc c est
combien à combien à combien de mois un
pigeon a perdu ma maturité ou le dit
vraiment pour l'empattement on parle de
jours deux jours deux jours non mais la
vision il répond avec usa puis je vois
ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
matelly qui a trois jours au par rapport
à l'autre par rapport avec qui a déjà
une quinzaine de journées
quoique
et c'est énorme et on voit bien que
dessous ses fils
c'est un bloc de bloc de chair et là tu
es là je m'attends à une quinzaine de
jours de grève
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mois suivant les fusions à des
restaurants tu fais comment exactement
les tous les pigeons sont vendus au
restaurant gastronomique les restaurants
gastronomiques les les 5 étoiles et les
hôtels cinq étoiles et tout ça est
disons que c'est une c'est une viande de
luxe avec plaisir c'est bah oui c'est
ben rien c'est ce que mon âme on coupe
du monde j'ai fait ma part que c'est la
même chose
voilà et jamal est entre nous entre nous
- secours de recettes préférées pigeons
il ya tellement le créole lui va
prochainement le pigeon aux petits pois
[Musique]
cette envolée perdu 15 de part peut-être
autour de l'autre
par exemple là ce soir que des petits
qui seront prêts pour l'abattoir la
semaine prochaine la la il a exactement
28 jours il mange quoi il va commencer
allemands du bayer 99 poissons de 90%
demailly et 10 poissons 2
d'aliments avec des protéines bon en
même temps c'est une volaille ben voilà
c'est une volaille donc ouais bah voilà
sauf que lui fait pas cocorico raucoules
[Musique]
visite à l'homme et à la réunion me
rappelle mon pépé n'avait de mon pépé
n'avait n'avait de pigeon tout le monde
aurait depuis juin vers le temps
tout le monde avait ses pigeonniers
partout mais c'est une tradition qui
s'est perdu au fil du temps et les
histoires tension seul et ça c'est
important ça mesdames et messieurs je
pense une histoire de tension qui a
toujours existé à la réunion mais qui
est archifaux il fait part de
l'intention non la zone pigeon non mon
attention c'est exactement comme si vous
mangez une amende et attention les
pigeons c'est exactement pareil
attention donc moment je pige on t'a
tensions n'ont pas fait les pigeons il
faut toujours denis parce que quand le
petit est arrivé à certains stades
la maman va recommencer a répondu tout
d'accord donc il lui faut un deuxième
demie mais comme j'ai grossi vite aussi
voilà et c'est le père qui continuent à
nourrir le petit en attendant que la
mère coup emma voilà et à chacun son
tour
[Musique]
dis moi tu ne travailles pas tu ne
travailles pas seule cette exploitation
quand même au début si on était ma femme
et moi et là on a employé deux fils avec
à les deux fusées dans à la piste voilà
qui sont avec moi voilà et là ça va
venir la famille de spécialités pigeons
mais tu disais aussi que pas mal de
personnes pendant sais que mon projet
était un peu bancal voire complètement
un projet de fou apparaître un projet
toqués way le pigeon les gens ils
n'arrivent pas à comprendre que le
pigeon c'est un animal comme comme le
poulet comme le canard c'est on peut
faire des lois aussi de pigeons donc
c'est un projet photo qu'est médoc et
auquel est vrai tant que ça là on est
dans la salle d'abattage les billons il
passe sur une plus meuse
voilà une fois passée la plume buzz ça
ira dans l'océan
un petit village express un petit
village express et une fois les piles à
chevigny mais il ya encore tout le tout
la partie finition à la main tous les
dernières petites plumes enlevé pour que
ce soit un produit impeccable après tout
c'est le seul helvète cher je voyais
releveurs pour l'instant peut-être que
dans après le 20h
mais finalement par le national c'est le
seul à la salle de la halle qu'eric
existants
[Musique]
alors là maintenant c'est un petit peu
de soleil tranquillement dis moi comment
oula arriver à faire de l'élevage de
pigeons parce que c'est quand même assez
rare vous
voire unique oui c'est une longue
histoire
on était dans la vache laitière et j'ai
eu un problème de santé
donc j'ai été obligé de changer de déjà
de tout vendre et abandonné à force de
rester sur place
il faut trouver quelque chose à faire
donc c'est là qu'on a qu'on est parti en
france et qu'on est tombé par hasard sur
un élevage de pigeons cher et c'est de
là que l'idée est partie pourquoi pas
bin tun oo mais nous en commun c'est le
fameux pose la colle que la nsa et un
petit bon chacun sacre avait cette île
aux oiseaux
on a toujours été un amateur d'oiseaux
un modèle et je verrai un élevage un
super élevage de canaris n'ont donc
c'est un oiseau que c'est on a toujours
été amateur d'oiseaux
alors vous avez dit manat des projets
mais ça ne me dit pas non plus dit pas
non ils pariaient déjà dit pas surprise
on va revenir faire une émission
ok y'a pas de soi il a fait des vagues
du crocodile pour la viande
nous l'avions bien coûte monsieur roche
mondiaux mais c'est beaucoup c'est moi
qui vous remercie déjà donné une idée
reçue clément balayé tension rien à voir
avec pigeons même si ça rime
voilà attention pigeon c'est en voilà
y'a rien à vous c'est pas vrai c'est pas
vrai du tout
voilà la prochaine aller et puis revoir
les terminaux
thomas
[Musique]
de par le balcon
il regarde pigeon la aux avirons et oui
messieurs dames
on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge c'est
terminé moi j'ai trouvé cette image
juste magnifique ipea politique ege flux
vous dire au revoir ici
à ce moment précis donc maille à la
prochaine nous retrouver sur tout on
n'est pas du tout sorti de l'auberge
[Musique]